katherine et ses canards l'histoire
démarre en 2005
un matin elle découvre un couple dans
son jardin l'adoption est automatique
catherine est une amoureuse des animaux
nous sommes quartier mmm lille et à
saint-joseph mobylette pour les jo
destin de cannes a fui des petits encore
des petits et l'élevage a commencé les
trois premiers jours ils ont un petit
bout jaune sur le sur le bec
je suis quelqu'un qui se lève tôt donc
dès 5 heures du matin on commence à déjà
les nourrir faire un prêt nettoyage pour
que tout le monde ait de l'eau propre un
jeu et d'en avoir un peu plus - de ce
sens
donc c'est très bien on voit qu'ils ont
de l'espace ils vivent
de plus après ces noms ça devient du
débit s'est passé pas le but recherché
c'est la petite exploitation j'ai mon
vétérinaire également donc
pas de souci voilà c'est pourquoi j'aime
faire tout dans les règles personne
là-bas le canard en fête sur la
martinique donc il a fallu
réagit on va dire donc j'ai fait ma
petite tuerie qui est donc aux normes et
donc régulièrement jabba une trentaine
par semaine du boulot et encore du
boulot jusqu'au bord de la rivière tout
construire seront un peu plus de deux
hectares tout nettoyer se former
catherine et opticienne dans la matinée
ensuite sur son terrain elle ne compte
plus les heures
j'ai pas l'étiquetage bio mais je
l'esprit l'esprit est là et respecter
mon solde justement dire ah ben tiens
ils sont toujours par terre non mais
justement la poudre blanche que vous
voyez c'est une poudre kaolin engine qui
en fait d'après un compost avec la terre
donc du coup c'est quand on prend la
terre en main on se dit mais c'est une
terme en effet toute sèche
s'assainissent 99% le sol un terrain
contrôlez pas de chlordécone seulement
deux longues journées et plus de
vacances se faire remplacer quand on a
des animaux à la maison c'est toujours
très compliqué